we're back to over-the-board play what
does it mean for you personally to be
playing in person it's irreplaceable i
think i mean online is cool and you know
we've all gotten used to it but there's
no substitute in my opinion for over the
board yes just the feeling of being
across from your opponent it feels i
don't know it feels like the proper way
to play chess yeah personally i'm i'm a
huge fan of playing just normal in
person and also classical it's just a
nice feeling to
to not be looking at a computer screen
to actually have your opponent in front
of you and there's a lot of new faces a
lot of players that i have haven't
played or have rarely played against so
that's also nice well i'm just so glad
that over the board chess was back i
mean it's what i live for i mean online
chess i'm
i'm incredibly thankful to like you know
st louis and the and the magnus tour for
having these online events when that's
all there was but there's really no
substitute for for over-the-board chess
and i had a really successful first
couple of events back i i sort of ran
out of steam a little bit in the last
couple and didn't play as well but um
i had some time to rest up so hopefully
i'm good to go here yeah i mean my last
big event was literally
two years ago yeah it's gonna be
interesting just to see how
i do uh if i still i'm able to play okay
or if i've
just gotten much worse over the past two
years but uh hopefully hopefully i've
also learned something
during that time period
throughout the year you play around 10
to 12 tournaments on average during the
pandemic when you don't play in the
over-the-board chess you kind of start
focusing on playing blitz in rapid and
that's more intuitive and actually
sitting at a board in thinking
luckily now that they're over the board
tournaments we can get back into that
mode of playing yeah obviously playing a
super term like the us championship is
always
a very honorable experience and
you know whether it's online or over the
board i'm always looking forward to to
the u.s championship and uh yeah should
be a very fun event yeah it's a huge
difference playing online and face to
face i like
playing online i did particularly one
last u.s championship but hopefully uh
over the board should be just fine as
well it's a great opportunity because i
haven't played
many tournaments
even before the
pandemic started so this is a great
opportunity to play over the world and
of course it is a kind of tournament
elite tournament that
i will face a ish round and great player
so it's very important for me
personally for me it's like playing over
the board feels more natural like i
prefer playing over the board rather
than online well it's a transition i i
have always been a fan of online chess
i've played almost exclusive i played
one tournament in two years so um of
course i'm incredibly excited to be back
over the board i think you know
everybody needs to understand that at
heart i'm an over-the-board player this
is what i'm
what i've grown up doing and this is
what i love to do so
it's going to be a bit of a transition
um obviously the time control it's not
blitz anymore so a bit of an adjustment
but i'm confident that i can make it
after the first couple games i really
like classical chess better i think it's
the real chess and you can't do
classical chess online
so
it just feels more prestigious having
this over the board